au Canada, nous voyons la diversité comme une source
de force et non de faiblesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
permettez-moi de dire très clairement que je suis incroyablement
fier d'être le fils de paralia Trudeau et
je suis incroyablement chanceux d'avoir été élevé
avec ces valeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je vais être enseignant
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
incroyableincroyable [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez un gouvernement avec une vision et
un programme pour ce pays qui est
positif et ambitieux et plein d'espoir bien
mes amis je vous promets ce soir que je
dirigerai ce gouvernement
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Musique]
vertigineusement
Mousavi au top Je vais continuer à dire
haut et fort que je suis une féministe
Je suis très concentré sur